major Garrett is at the white house
major what are you hearing from
administration officials do they believe
this is a negotiating ploy
well good morning today President Trump
finds himself in a situation many North
Korea experts predicted he might in the
weeks leading up to this potential
summit what is that a place where North
Korea is showing hesitation and putting
new demands on the table now for months
I think it's fair to say president Trump
has been the unpredictable force in
these conversations now Kim jong-un is
playing the same game how is he playing
it by trying to redefine what it means
to abandon nuclear weapons and how
evidence of that abandonment would be
confirmed North Korea objects-- to US
inspections u.s. destruction of its
underlying nuclear weapons technology so
far all the White House will say is that
it will continue to coordinate closely
with allies and independently react and
judge what the North Koreans have said
as has always been true the definition
of denuclearization has been at the
heart on the relationship between North
Korea and the u.s. optimism the D
nucleation denuclearization could be
achieved is running into a struggle over
that very definition and that struggle
will define whether there's a summit and
how successful if one occurs it will be
the State Department is scrambling to
figure out if North Korea is just
negotiating employ tactics or if this
threat to pullout is actually real what
is clear is this has cast a bit of a
pall over what appeared to be a warming
relationship between Washington and
Pyongyang guys certainly more to come on
that thank you very much major a lot at
stake here